und jetzt begrüße ich siegfried russwurm
den präsidenten des bundesverbandes der
deutschen industrie heraus von guten
morgen guten irgendwann berlin wir haben
gerade gesehen 60 prozent
preissteigerung allein beim gas gestern
was bedeutet das für deutsche
unternehmen
ja die bilder die wir aus der ukraine
sehen wie machen uns ja alle wütend sind
top emotional
staaten menschen und glaubt niemand kann
das einfach von sich weg nehmen aber wir
müssen bei allem wie wir darauf
reagieren dürfen wir rationalität nicht
ausschalten
energie ist teuer geworden sehr teuer
geworden für die endverbraucher aber
auch für die industrie und wir haben
halt viele industriezweige für die der
energieeinsatz ein ganz wesentlicher
kostenfaktor da wird es zumindest nimmt
schwierig noch vernünftig produzieren zu
können ohne nur braucht zulegen darüber
hinaus gibt es ja jetzt eine diskussion
ob wir nicht ganz auf russisches gas
verzichten sollen um den druck zu
erhöhen das würde finanziell russland
hart treffen aber uns ja auch was sagen
sie
das ist so ein punkt wo man aufpassen
muss nicht emotional zu reagieren
sondern sehr rational brauch zu schauen
und glaube es wäre naiv das bild zu
glauben dass die einnahmen aus dem
verkauf von gas und öl jetzt akut diesen
krieg finanzieren warum ihr putin hat
aufgerüstet seine panzer müssen sich an
die tankstelle fahren und auch eine
rechnung bezahlen das heißt die
argumentation wir finanzieren diesen
krieg heute mit jedem kubikmeter gas dem
wir heute kaufen die stimmt rational
nicht auf der anderen seite fällt es uns
schwer um zu stellen das ist nichts der
bundeskanzler hat völlig recht dass hat
nichts was innerhalb weniger tage
passieren kann und deswegen sollten wir
alles tun diese eskalation zu vermeiden
auch wenn es emotional vor dem
hintergrund dieser bilder unendlich
schwer fällt heraus warum sprechen wir
über die harten sanktionen die gegenüber
russland verhängt wurden das trifft ja
auch unternehmen in deutschland die
geschäfte mit russland machen wie hart
trifft dass diese firmen das ist sehr
unterschiedlich da gibt es nicht ein
muster und der durchschnitt sagt wenig
aus viele unternehmen verkaufen einfach
ihre produkte nach russland haben muss
jetzt eingestellt teilweise wegen der
sanktionen viele aber auch obwohl sie
gar nicht explizit von sanktionen
betroffen sind weil sie mit diesem
geschehen keine geschäfte machen wollen
auf der anderen seite gibt es
unternehmen die sehr eng verbunden sind
mit dem leben in der in russland mit der
nahrungsmittelversorgung dort für die
ist die frage ob sie denn ersatzteile
für ihre produkt belieferten die dort
eingesetzt werden nicht einfach zu
beantworten und für alle die in russland
und in der ukraine engagiert sind war
und ist die erste priorität wie geht es
eigentlich unsere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter können wir ihnen helfen
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hat ja hilfe signalisiert für diese
firmen die direkt durch die russland
sanktionen betroffen sind manche
vielleicht sogar von der pleite
betroffen sind wird das reichen oder
fordern sie mehr
ich habe in diesen zeiten ist fordern
einfach die falsche vokabel es gibt eine
klare verabredung mit dem
bundesfinanzminister mit der ganzen
regierung dass man sich die einzelfälle
anschauen wird das sind nicht unendlich
viele man muss schauen wie man
unternehmen helfen kann wie tatsächlich
in echte schwierigkeiten kommen weil zb
ihre investitionen in russland plötzlich
wertlos sind aber noch mal es ist nicht
die zeit für forderungen es ist zeit
dafür dass wir uns in deutschland
vorbereiten auf eine situation die
leider auch noch schwieriger werden herr
wussten sie haben eben die firmen
angesprochen die von sich aus ihr
geschäft mit russland eingeschränkt
haben keine waren mehr verkaufen wollen
dort als signal vw ist ein beispiel
adidas auch ist das nicht ein bisschen
spät das unternehmen haben davor gute
geschäfte gemacht mit russland in
russland und ja schon vor diesem ukraine
krieg hatte putin blut an den händen hat
gegen internationales recht verstoßen da
ist die creme nur ein beispiel von
vielen
das ist sicher richtig auf der anderen
seite haben wir dadurch gesprächskanäle
offen gehalten in der politik in der
diplomatie auch in der wirtschaft
ein austausch und wir müssen uns sehr
gut überlegen wie wir damit weiter
umgehen wladimir putin hat sich ins
abseits gestellt er hatte die chance
noch vor zehn jahren in die
geschichtsbücher einzugehen als der
herrscher russlands ja dieses land ins
21 jahrhundert führt er hat sich
entschieden für den anderen weg er hat
sie völlig ins abseits gestellt deswegen
macht es jetzt wenig sinn über die
vergangenheit zu reden außer dass wir
daraus lernen können und abhängigkeiten
zu wie sie die aus russland entstanden
sind für unsere energieversorgung in der
zukunft nicht mehr eingehen der blick
auf die wirtschaft und auf die deutschen
firmen war das hier im zdf morgenmagazin
der präsident des bundesverbandes der
deutschen industrie siegfried russwurm
vielen dank ich danke